Now when you have these considerations,
when you take these actions,
do you consult with psychologists or sociologists or historians or people that
try to put in perspective for you?
What the ramifications of each individual move would be?
I try to read as much as possible.
I tried to talk to as many people as possible.
Just get completely different perspective.
And
is there any internal disagreement about actions that you take?
Oh yeah,
there's,
there's always,
there's always debate,
there's always debate.
But I think my role is to ask,
ask questions and make sure like are like what,
what is our goal here?
What are we trying to do?
Um,
you know,
and that evolves that'll,
that evolves,
that evolves like [inaudible] is this over the long term going to be a net
positive for all humans,
all,
all humanity.
Like how do we balance the considerations of,
of,
you know,
how we serve everyone and like how do we get down to something,
how do we get down to a fundamental answer in the central answer?
And that to me is where the real truth is,
is when you can get to something foundational.
But I like,
you know,
I like having conversations with as many people from as many different fields as
possible and getting their perspective on it.
So I ask questions all the time.
It's interesting the way you're phrasing this too,
that you,
you are looking at this as a method to save or to her to help people,
to serve people.
You're looking at this as a way that you can benefit society,
the society can benefit from your platform,
can benefit from this disability to communicate.
Um,
you're not just looking at it as a tech company that has to remain profitable
and is one of the more interesting things about tech companies to me.
I mean,
there's been a lot of criticism,
maybe justified in some ways the tech companies all lean left.
But what is it interesting to me is that w name another corporation that
willingly of its own choice takes that into consideration that they,
they want to serve the world and surf culture in a beneficial way regardless of
profit.
Yeah.
I mean,
because you're not really selling anything,
right?
You guys have a platform,
obviously it's financially viable,
but you're not,
you're not selling things.
Well.
I mean,
we,
we do our models based off people's attention and they're paying us with our
attention and that's extremely valuable and something that we need to really,
really honor.
Um,
but I agree with you.
I mean like,
look at,
look at Tesla,
you know,
there,
I'd,
I just listened to,
uh,
um,
the,
the recent earnings call on,
one of the things that you on said was,
look,
there are two reasons,
uh,
for a Tesla.
Number one is to advance,
um,
uh,
you know,
different sources of,
of energy and more renewable sources of energy because it's a fundamental and
existential crisis that's facing all humanity.
And number two is to advance autonomy because it'll save lives and give people
time back.
And,
you know,
then you started talking about how to make that possible.
And that's where,
you know,
our business comes in.
How do we,
how do we make that possible?
And we,
we have,
uh,
we have a great business.
We,
we need to improve all bunch of it.
But we,
it,
it serves what we think our larger purposes,
which is serving the public conversation.
We want to see more global public conversations.
We want to,
we want our technology to be used to make the world feel a lot smaller,
to help see what common problems we have before us.
And ideally,
uh,
you know,
how we can get people together to solve them faster and solve them better.
You also seem to be embracing this responsibility that you're,
you're helping to evolve culture and this is part of the PR providing this
method of communication,
of communication.
Rather it's helping to evolve culture.
And this is,
uh,
this is something that is really only applicable to tech companies in some
strange way.
And it's weird that so many of them have share this.
Like I was personally a little weirded out when Google took out.
Don't be evil.
Like that was a big part of their operating model.
Take that out.
Yes,
yes.
Right.
Make sure that I don't wanna get sued.
I'm pretty sure they remove that from,
what would you call that?
There,
there are operational directive,
like what is was in the code of conduct,
code of conduct.
And it's not there anymore.
Right?
They're moving to article that says they removed the clause.
And this is kind of a weird thing to tell people not to be evil is where did it
take it out once you've already said it,
it's way weirder to say af fuck it,
we were wrong.
There's another way of saying that they changed it to do the right thing.
Yeah.
Oh well what does that mean?
The fuck does do the right thing mean do the right things so you can make more
money.
You know,
like,
Hey,
we're gonna make money.
We'll do the right thing.
It makes more money.
I mean that's,
that's why like,
that's why this openness is so critical.
I mean,
that's,
that's why I liked the public comment to me that public conversation is so
important is we can talk about stuff like that and like there'll be companies
forming today that look at,
um,
objectives and mandates like that and base their whole,
culture around it.
And is that the right idea?
I don't know,
but if we're not talking about it,
we won't be able to answer that question.